Shawn is with us in Colorado Springs hey
Shawn how are you good day thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
so as of June 6 my family and I are on
baby step 7
yay yeah right so I I teach a lot at
work about your theories of money and
your principles but a lot of people
argue this whole credit thing so I
wanted to prove to somebody you can get
a mortgage on a zero credit score so I
called some lenders and they're telling
me no quick and mortgage and USAA
that's because quick and mortgage and
USAA don't hire underwriters they are
monkeys and a monkey can make a FICO
score credit alums mortgage that not
everybody does manual underwriting it's
not a hundred percent out there it
requires more work from the mortgage
company to make a loan to someone who
has a zero credit score but Churchill
mortgage will do one and and the
interest rate is exactly the same as the
interest rate no penalties on the
interest rate for it being zero but yeah
you can't get a loan from quicken which
by the way and free can get a loan from
quicken anyway I mean rocket mortgage
give me a break seriously I mean you
this is your home mortgage you're gonna
deal with online geeks no no get a
traditional mortgage company that knows
what the flip they're doing that
actually knows how to do underwriting
and they're not monkeys making loans you
know point the number mmm if I was to
ever do a mortgage again I would follow
your principles 15-year fixed yeah yeah
and I would use Church in mortgage but I
want to know can I substantiate what I'm
saying to people by calling turtle
mortgage you can yeah by calling rocket
mortgage now because they don't make
loans that way not everybody makes loans
on a manual underwriting process it's
more work for the mortgage company so
it's up to that particular mortgage
company whether they want to go to all
that trouble or not and these online
groups that are cranking through widgets
and their customers are numbers they're
not ever gonna give you high levels of
service like that yes sir I appreciate
it I will represent a Tercel mortgage
enough and other mortgage companies that
you know have a full-service team that
know how to do what you're looking for
called manual underwriting and then
you're just fine to do that but yeah if
you just want to walk out there and get
a loan from a monkey no you can't get
one with no credit score doesn't monkey
can't compute that they don't know how
to do it they don't know how to deal
with that you know point the number the
number that's the whole loan is made
based on the number and actually it's a
dumb but way of making a mortgage if you
think about it because you can have a
big number no job you could have a big
number and no down payment you could
have a big number and get the loan and
these low doc no doc loans that are set
up or what caused the last financial
crisis and now we're back to doing them
again because you're loaning people that
shouldn't be getting money money and
then you get them in trouble but that's
aside from the issue so anyway you do
what you want to do and that's the thing
but here's the thing convincing people
at work you're not going to convince all
of them I've been doing this for 30
years there are entire websites devoted
to how stupid Dave Ramsey is well I'm
sitting here making people millionaires
left and right and I'm a
multi-millionaire doing the stupid stuff
I teach so you're not gonna convince a
whole lot of people those convinced
against their will or of the same
opinion still a lot of people are just
gonna continue to go get a car loan
they're always going to have a credit
card that you know what are we arguing
about here we're arguing about
I want to go borrow money okay go borrow
money stupid you know I'm gonna argue
with you it's stupid it's not the
shortest path to building wealth it's
stupid I'm not gonna argue with you
about that and Shawn you shouldn't be
that's what you ought to have in your
head now you don't be that rude to your
co-workers but in your mind you gotta go
you know you're just too stupid to help
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]